hey youtubers its charlie Thank You
everybody that's many questions on my
Game of Thrones video yesterday everyone
completely upset about what happened in
the episode actually just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet so we can just start talking about
it in case you guys didn't see Dan and
Dave said the george RR martin explained
to them what was going to happen to
Shireen eventually so that's why she
ended up getting put to the torch so
even though it hasn't happened in the
books yet he implied that it would be
happening or it would have happened had
events gone down that way just to
clarify george RR martin said that
because of the changes the show has made
people will be dying on the show that
did not die in the books so what he's
done with Dan and Dave is helped them
with the character arcs so given the
circumstances that Stannis is faced with
this is the decision that George R
Martin felt he would have made the
gamble he would have made it's a really
big gamble he's betting that Melisandre
is right even though Shireen isn't dead
in the books right now she probably
would have ended up that way it just
might end up happening up at the wall
that's what the implication is okay it's
on to questions Frank Gleason do you
think what happened to Shireen on the
show will happen in the books as well
well you know based on what George RR
Martin's said yes it will happen
probably in a slightly different way
though and for slightly different
reasons in the books Stannis left
Shireen at the wall whenever he marched
on Winterfell so if she's gonna be
sacrificed it's not gonna be till
Stannis gets back and there are a lot of
spoiler theories as to why Melisandre
might need more king's blood up at the
wall we could talk about that after the
finale though to just put a bookmark in
that next question Blackfyre asks so now
that Stannis has burned his daughter and
drank the last of Mel's Lord of Light
punch
how will Davos react once he returns
will this be the final straw that causes
him to abandon Stannis I don't know
about abandon him but he's definitely
going to be questioning his faith it's a
nice balance with what's going on with
Tyrion and Daenerys right now whenever
Daenerys took off on drogon that was a
moment of pure belief for Tyrion he is
no longer a doubter he he totally drinks
the dragon kool-aid Davos is probably
gonna have the opposite reaction when he
learns about Shireen and there's no
telling how long it's gonna be before he
finds out he left to go to the wall
before Stannis visited Shireen so he has
absolutely no idea what happened I I
think they're kind of setting him up to
get an Ali type arc like he's like the
ally of Stannis is camp right now Jon
went to get the wildlings a decision
that seemed
awful at the time but long-term was
supposed to pay off Stannis was trying
to do the same thing like he's rolling
the dice a little bit he sacrificed his
daughter awful think hoping that the
payoff long-term would be worth it so I
think Davos is gonna react the Stannis
in a similar way that all he is reacting
to Jon Snow next question
Noah asks so is there no leader of the
harpy then his Darsh said everything is
sorted out but he didn't try to kill
Daenerys well you know just because he
didn't try to stab her with a knife
doesn't mean that he's not associated
with the harpies and I know everyone's
wondering is he dead is he not dead we
did see him get stabbed by the harpies a
lot go down we didn't see his body after
he fell if you remember back when grey
worm and Barristan Selmy got attacked
think about how much grey worm got
stabbed he's still alive
so until we see Daenerys standing over
his dog's body or them remarking on his
dart being dead I think we have to
assume that he's still alive I'm totally
expecting the finale to answer that
question definitively though it feels
like what they're suggesting with
Daenerys is Ark is that she is going to
suppress the noble houses of murine in
order to do that she's gonna have to go
into like Mad King territory though next
question James asks do you see Daenerys
his connection with drogon developing
further and do you think she's gonna
release the two remaining dragons and
use them against the sons of the harpy I
definitely think that they're going to
explore her connection with the dragons
more as for releasing the dragons I feel
like they're teasing that but it remains
to be seen
if she shows up in the finale at all
actually I should say yeah she's
definitely gonna be in the finale
there's no way they'd leave her out she
put the Dragons in Chains to appease the
people but based on what happened to the
pit I think the time for that is over it
would be a small change from the book so
if that doesn't have happening in the
finale I'll explain what's different
about the books because it involves like
a character that they've cut off of the
show but definitely plan to see more
Dragon Fire next question Sammy asks how
much time has passed in the story since
the first season so you're asking like
you know the beginning of season one
what's the timeline usually I mean
approximately a year per season but they
kind of blur the lines in the last two
seasons
next question doc usain asks Lady
Stoneheart she said you know like on the
show not on the show
strictly speaking as it happens in the
books no Lady Stoneheart but it is
possible they could be doing a version
of her with another character
of all the candidates of all the people
they could turn into a lady stoneheart
type character I think it would be Sansa
they've made her look more and more like
her mother every year magically speaking
it would have to happen as a consequence
of Stannis's sacrifice like an
unintended consequence all just
speculation and theories though I'm not
expecting Lady Stoneheart but I will be
really happy if they do go that
direction
next question Hattie asks why did the
sons of the harpy look like they were
attacking the slave families in the
stands if the sons are supposed to be
working for said families yeah you're
asking like what did it look like the
harpies were indiscriminately just
stabbing the hell out of people I think
that they were just trying to cause
chaos they wanted an heiress to feel
completely helpless and kill any
supporters that she might have in that
arena it'd be like if half of the Nights
Watch brothers that hate Jon Snow
murdered the other half that liked him
next question Zuccarello asks i think
i'm pronouncing that name right what
kind of power will Melisandre and
Stannis gain with the sacrifice of
Shireen probably you know some
intangible benefits in some practical
effects hopefully a big twist to
something that they did not ask for
intangibly I think what mello Sanders
hoping to do is affect the probability
of the battle make it so that everything
that needs to happen ends up happening
so that Stannis can win unexpected
benefits though this is actually the big
one what I'm hoping is as a couple
characters die and are resurrected
because of the sacrifice
Melisande has been really vague on what
exactly he's going to get with that
sacrifice usually what happens is is she
sees visions and flames so she wanted to
perform the sacrifice to bring about a
more favorable outcome the thing about
that though is is that Melisandre has
been known to miss interpret her visions
in the book she says that Arya will come
to the wall but it ends up being the
fake Arya Jane Poole so this thing
whereby you get what you asked for but
not what you thought you asked for
next question Zacharias asks how is one
dragon worth 8,000 unsullied so you're
saying you know like how did he defeat
the sons of the harpy so easily there is
something that they haven't really
explained on the show but it's called
dragon fear way back during Aegon's
conquest when they had the three dragons
including you know blaring the black
dread what would happen is he would send
the dragons to burn the field between
both armies and the opposing army would
all just crap their pants and give up
their
so terrified by the sight of a dragon
that they couldn't even fight so I think
they wanted to apply that a little bit
of that was happening in des nak spit
next question Cthulhu asks soda rain
mentions four favorite nieces do you
feel like will Caesar Ellis and next
season well it's possible that was just
an easter egg for the books or it was a
mistake by the actors part that they
just let slide I think that it was
intentional they're pretty careful about
the way they edit episodes it's possible
that they're just a couple of daughters
like really young daughters that we
haven't seen they made a lot of changes
to ilaria sand from the books in the
books she is the mother of Oberyn
Martell for youngest daughters none of
them are on the show right now there's
Elia Oh Bela daraya and Larissa in the
context of the show I think what they're
doing is is they're giving her those
four youngest ones from the books that
they just they haven't cast on the show
and tyene sand so technically she has
five daughters I'm not expecting to see
him on the show next year because they
already have the sand snakes now and
they're probably is gonna roll harder on
them what they might do is if they were
intending to do sir Ellis plot from the
books in season six they'll give it to a
different sand snake like Nymeria as for
where the other four daughters are I'm
guessing they're playing off somewhere
in the water gardens and we'll never see
them next question Ellie asks is there
any significance that Jon Snow has Jorah
Mormont's family's ancestral Valyrian
blade Longclaw so what you're asking is
is like is anything can happen with
Jorah at the wall with Longclaw because
it's put his Valyrian blade and those
are really important in fighting white
walkers it seems like but you know based
on the amount of time it takes greyscale
to set in he could make it to the time
when Daenerys is fighting White Walkers
which I think you know avenge eventually
will come whether or not it's season six
or season seven but for all intents and
purposes I think that Jorah gave up that
blade for good when he left
and it's actually Joris younger sister I
think that is in control of Bear Island
right now she's the one that sent the
blade up to the wall to Jo or moment
when he was still alive
and I think that the old bear is so
ashamed by what his son did that he gave
it to Jon and it felt like he was giving
it a good home so I think it will stay
with Jon Snow
if you're talking about Jorah seeing the
sword at the wall in triggering some
sort of redemptive arc in him I actually
I think that's what happened in this
episode for him this
his Redemption but yeah I don't think
they're gonna make any any dramatic
changes to John snows weaponry other
than he might start carrying around a
dragon glass dagger justjust as a backup
thank you so much everyone for so many
questions these are always a ton of fun
to do what's gonna happen this week is
I'm gonna do a few extra bonus videos
just because we're heading into the
finale and then I'll settle into like my
summer Game of Thrones bonus video
schedule so just stay tuned for updates
on that and I will still continue to do
the weekly Game of Thrones giveaway
whenever I post bonus videos and don't
forget we have Comic Con coming up -
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner Chris you in an HBO now
subscription just be sure to message me
or you know DM me on the back end of my
channel if you're not sure where to do
that it's on the about page I still have
one signed copy of a feast for crows so
what I'm probably gonna do is use that
for my finale giveaway because a lot of
you asked for an azure 'hi night's king
video I'm gonna post that in a couple
days I'm not gonna wait till Sunday to
post that so while you guys wait for all
that stuff to post you can click here to
learn all about ash I the the place that
Melisandre comes from she's a shadow
binder and you can click here for my
episode 9 video thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you